we'll close it out this is the last
debate club
okay guys who's he think he looks like
oh i know who that birdman that played
for charlotte
what's his name chris anderson chris
anderson chris anderson
you want me to bring him up does it no
he doesn't look like chris anderson does
this guy think he looks like [ __ ]
well let him say what he wants to say
first i think people tell me i look like
lamar jackson all the time
okay guys would you rather live
through the hurricane katrina again or
lived through the uh earthquakes that
hit the bay area
in late 80s early 90s during the world
series
gang gang buzz buzz and and i'm a member
of the joey diaz church too
so go [ __ ] your mother [ __ ]
i love it man you gotta throw that in
there you gotta throw it in bro
uh i'll tell you right now i'd rather
lift through both of those than this
[ __ ]
pandemic ran right now i'll take any of
those over this pandemic
oh he definitely looks like chris
anderson a little bit didn't that guy
play for denver too
yeah he played everywhere um i
great and what is he saying does he look
like he was in the christian earthquake
buddy no he didn't look like you know he
was saying would you rather get trapped
in an earthquake or trapped under the
levees in new orleans specifically be be
in the night
would you rather live through the
earthquake or earthquake the
earthquake's the one-time hitter it's
gonna do some [ __ ] damage but at
least you can
go about your business if you don't get
trapped under a goddamn building
i don't i i that's a wild one the
hurricane's [ __ ] like think about the
hurricanes like the levy in new orleans
it destroyed the city
the the earthquakes don't even wrong it
[ __ ] stuff up in san francisco
especially on the bridges but for the
most part everyone was okay
how many people died in that earthquake
nick again i'd rather take both of those
in this
[ __ ] pandemic did you know malik and
his family moved here because of
hurricane katrina yeah did they really
he's from new orleans mm-hmm oh i didn't
know that yeah
yeah his family yeah they had to move
here when the train went down wow
three thousand people that's a lot of
people yeah how many
that's how many people died in september
11th is it yeah
3 000 1800 in katrina that's interesting
because you almost would have thought i
would have thought that katrina was more
me too yeah you know why because it's
recent and you're from new orleans
that's a good point so it's probably
really bad in your eyes what do you guys
think what would you rather
uh have you been an earthquake right
being here you've been small ones
because i'm from the bay area yeah
i mean i would take earthquakes just
because i'm more accustomed to it
that's an asian stereotype i will say a
lot of people think that you guys have
been an earthquake
really i haven't heard that i didn't
realize that until just now i just
realized that i was like oh wow
right when he said that i mean i was
like yeah cat's been an earthquake dude
i get tsunamis earthquakes yeah it's
crazy
there's something i think about viruses
maybe also like
people that are more from like a
filipino you i guess in my head i would
think those you think earthquakes i
think tsunamis
or tsunamis something like that i feel
like you guys are way more likely to
have been through a natural disaster i
didn't realize that that is a stereotype
earthquakes cause tsunamis they do
[Laughter]
okay mr discovery channel jesus
have you been in a natural disaster
a natural disaster yeah an earthquake
yeah earthquake
tsunami lightning whorehouse getting a
bunch of
natural disasters on the water on icy
roads and i've also been
in a natural disaster here because i'm
like high up in a building all right
don't brag
last earthquake it felt like it was
about to topple over wow
yeah yeah because you know you know all
the villains in la's the tall sky rides
are on rollers
so they sway with the earthquake really
nice to have a sky rides in uh marina
del rey
calm down and i know that's the time
y'all rich
right it would sway during the
earthquake really they're built to sway
that i'll sway too from mtv yeah charles
swift uh
yeah yeah he's not on mtv anymore but
yeah oh yeah i think he's
he's on cirrus right and he has his own
show yeah you should go on there and
freestyle
you think yeah do that i can't even get
you freestyling here with me i tried i
can't freestyle
but neither can i i know and that's why
we shouldn't do it yeah
what do you think i grew up in arizona
like we don't have like
much like we have those uh no
the haboobs it's like a massive dust
storm you want to touch right through
oh wow you've never seen them we looked
at it before it's nick though yeah it's
dude
huge it's like a huge dust storm but you
guys have heat waves where you can't
leave the house
i go out there what are they going to do
when it's like 120. i've been out there
and y'all have road runners don't y'all
have road runners in there
they don't look like the cartoon phoenix
together yeah those things kill rabbits
they're built like brian yeah you never
seen a roadrunner take down the
rattlesnake
it like you know it catches it bites it
and then it just starts slamming it to
the
the small ground they do have that hip
dexterity so yeah we get a lot of these
uh
cloud cover so see that oh
oh that's like from the movie the mummy
i've never seen it but
the mummy comes out and he faces in the
sand he gets the plane
with brendan frazier shout out to
brendan yeah
[Laughter]
he's so excited yeah correct
but yeah that's what we get so that's
like that guy's driving right into
a psychopath some people don't give up
that guy's going to kill his family
obviously
just driving straight forward yeah he's
flying
yeah you have to like like if you're
driving like you have to like because it
comes over like pretty
quickly you just so you just pull over
as it passes
it doesn't seem too bad it's not bad
yeah that's what we see that
yeah yeah that and then the uh makes you
want to get some coke and drive a
[ __ ] rx7 right through that [ __ ]
yeah yeah all right paul walker hell
yeah well
look it but look at look what happens
when you're driving it
watch that thing get that rattlesnake
watch him yeah they're small
there's bro it's it's insane whip baby
watch me nae nae
this thing yeah they don't they don't
look like the cartoon though do they
no they do are you just gonna buy that
bite that thing by the tail
okay you decide to pass i think i found
another one
that was a terrible video i know nick
what was that
they get you they'll get a rattlesnake
oh that's a baby dude no it'll go after
bigger ones
this is chin killing a
we rattlesnake too many windows great
video chin this is chin killing a baby
rattlesnake
y'all never been in a hooboo no man no
all right
i feel like there's a better video to
watch nick i mean that first one nothing
no look it look right there that one
here we go best
now oh look at this intense
i don't like birds what is this ufc 254
yeah
so look it yeah gadget it gets it oh
there's cheeto vera right there
and then boom look at it
are you just boom [ __ ]
get you some that's the move i'm gonna
put on you [ __ ] do it [ __ ]
i will son you built like a bird i'll
[ __ ] inch i'll bite your arms off the
[ __ ] body
dead i'll bite one of your legs off you
idiot are they immune to the venom
i think they are some animals are uh
yeah some animals
are that honey badger is